hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today
is my wife julie pyatt
she's been on the podcast a million
times most people know her
as a plant-based chef a best-selling
cookbook author
as a yogi and a healer but today we're
going to do something
a little bit different sort of my guy
ras how i built this
take on my wife's life as a
serial entrepreneur tracking her
trajectory all the way
up to her becoming this doyenne of vegan
cheese with her
plant-based cheese startup shrimpu it's
a great conversation
you guys are going to really enjoy it
lots of stuff we've never talked about
before
and before we get into it just a
reminder hit that subscribe button
and that notification bell so you can be
alerted every time we
post a new video and with that please
enjoy my conversation
with my wife julie piatt
[Music]
julie piet how long has it been since
we've done a podcast
it's been i think six months rich roll
has it been that long i think so aren't
we in quarantine six months
now yeah but did we do one at the
beginning of course right at the
beginning oh we did i want to say it was
maybe like
five days in this might be the longest
that we've gone
without i've missed you a check-in
i mean since the beginning of the
podcast you being on episode one and on
every initial episode we've always done
a podcast here and there every couple
months or so so
this might be the longest interlude but
now you have another lover
that you're doing your q and a's with
with adam yes
yes the roll-ons it's amazing it's
really really good
well it's nice to see you thank you
honey we could use this as a
as a referendum on our marriage how do
you think our marriage is doing right
now it's holding up
it's definitely yeah we're six months
into quarantine it's been an interesting
ride it's had its high highs and low
lows and
everything in between i suppose i think
that i um
i've had more emotional peaks and
valleys with it than you have you seem
pretty consistent
well um consistent unless i'm on the
frequency of our teenage daughters right
well that's been the challenge the
biggest challenge of this
for us and our family really has been
trying to
help our our our daughters navigate the
vicissitudes of
what what's being thrown at us yeah or
how to how to realize that our daughters
don't want our
help what's going on in quarantine but
it's been
really unprecedented and i i think this
is a global issue we were
teasing last night about um my son was
saying
if if every parent of a teen could do
some documentary footage and it could be
called
quarantine yeah so
uh it's been trying for everyone and i
know
i'm checking in with our uh pediatrician
he's seen levels of anxiety that are
unprecedented in our
teenage years yeah i mean you know for
people that don't know or if you're new
to the show
uh there's six of us cohabitating right
now
two older boys uh 25 and 24 tyler and
trapper
who moved home at the beginning of
quarantine from their apartment
in in echo park which is kind of in the
hollywood area
and then our daughters who are 13 and 16
and
overall it's been a delight to have
everybody at home
really precious family time and i always
try to keep that in the forefront
of my consciousness and my awareness
but it's been really hard for uh the
girls
and also you know just bearing witness
to
um the difficulties that a lot of our
friends and
are having with their kids and it's
really you know
i feel like the emotional mental
impact of this on young people is
really not fully um
addressed in the grand scheme of trying
to get through this in a healthy way
like yes
we don't want to get the virus yes we
need to do all the things and
be safe and protect our children but
there's also a cost to all of this and
we're seeing that cost being borne out
and it will be interesting
to see the long-term implications on
this generation this young generation
and how this experience impacts
decisions that they make and choices
that they make later in life
yeah definitely and i think it's you
know like you said i've been pretty
consistent and you know there's many
things about
quarantine that i actually prefer i
prefer being at home with my family
and creating meals together and
you know having time to reflect and
slow down and i think that quarantine
provides sort of like an ayurvedic
prescriptive healing
experience for us and i do really
believe overall that many of us
if we are the ones that don't choose to
exit or
leave the body you know for various
reasons during this time
that we will have gained years onto our
life because of the slowing down
you know we see these benefits to the
planet to the air
to the waters and yet you know we have
the perspective of having lived a very
full life
behind us we've experienced many things
in our lives and even our sons who are
in their 20s
um you know it's very hard to imagine
how they must feel
you know reflecting on what their future
is going to be like
what's going to be available to them and
it's hard for us to really imagine
what all these conditions present in the
psyche of a teen
of a young child and you know just
recently one of our daughters
she was she's very concerned you know
she was basically telling us
we needed to move that we were not safe
and you know this is a very real
emotional state that children are
experiencing that we're all
experiencing in different ways yeah the
mental
emotional fallout is very real and you
know at least with respect to our 16
year old daughter
she's not interested in any prescription
coming from us right
she's trying to craft her own identity
and contradiction to us like
she's trying to figure out who she is by
pushing the boundaries of
um you know kind of our lifestyle
parameters
and part of that's healthy because
that's how she figures out who she is
but also it makes it challenging when
we're all cohabitating and we're trying
to
be helpful to her and she's resistant to
hearing anything from us
that's right well it's healthy for her
and very uh challenging for us
trying for us but but there are
beautiful moments within that journey
and
and i find the energy going up and down
a lot more rapidly like within a week
span there's a lot of different
colors of experience that i'm having
within the family and i think the
you know the beauty is being able to go
on that journey
and just be present in the moment to
what's happening so
you know sometimes there's a lot of
screaming and tears
and uh you know bumping up against rub
rough edges
and then other times slamming yeah
there's a lot of sweetness though too
and moments that are just stolen um that
never would have happened if we weren't
sequestered if we weren't quarantined so
there are a lot of treasures that are
available to us
um it's a it's an intense time for sure
yeah you know i i vacillate between
being
totally fine with the whole thing and
despairing like i miss the travel i miss
being able to
you know plan adventures and have things
to look forward to
on the calendar and when one day just
bleeds into the next
everything starts to feel a little bit
mundane and that's when i
get into a funk but you really are able
to
surf it more gracefully than than i do
and i suspect a lot of that has to do
with your own spiritual practice and
these kind of rituals that you've set up
like you get up at three or four in the
morning and you do
a fire ceremony and then you're out we
have an outdoor
tub and you're out in the bathtub under
the star you do a lot like before
anybody else wakes up in the morning
you've already lived like an entire day
it's true i mean those are um for me i
don't know
where i would be if i didn't have my
deep
connection to my faith and the spiritual
perspective of what is going on
um i don't know how i would feel without
that
it has been really a treasure
of connection to understand that
there is a greater plan that
um this is a moment of of immense
transformation
and uh believing and and
living in the awareness that we
incarnated for this purpose
like we all chose to come into a body
during this time
at this unprecedented moment and what
the opportunity is to
participate in evolution
and also creating a brighter world
a higher vibrating experience for
humanity
for animals for the planet and
even beyond this realm so how do you
remain grounded in that
conviction when you open up your phone
and start scrolling
through you know the various versions of
vitriol and
dissonance and discontent and argument
that
seems to be kind of the touchdown of
2020 especially
as we you know near this election
and with the fires that we've been
dealing like there's so much
um upheaval right now across the world
and it's easy to say well this is a
moment of transformation
and this is an opportunity but i just
know for myself
like exposing myself to too much of that
really starts to
become disheartening to me yeah but
that's true
and so there's a lot of it right like
unprecedented
um darkness being revealed in all areas
of our life
and what i think this does is it starts
to communicate to us that
we've been living in illusion we
we were maybe thinking that we were
living a different life than what we
really
were living so in my awareness it's sort
of like the light goes on
and you're seeing everything scurrying
around but it was always there
it's not like it just is existing now
it's
sort of like the uh the result of
of our collective actions of the aspects
of what it
means to incarnate in planet earth with
with all of its polarity
and all of its contrast and so
it's sort of revealing the truth of what
is and i think the opportunity
is to understand that everything is
being gaslit
every single perspective that is being
presented
has the potential to have been
manipulated
and so what do we do with that yeah it's
really hard to find your footing
yeah how do you how do you you know who
can you trust what channel are you going
to trust
what person are you going to trust and
in my
spiritual journey of my life it has led
me to know that we can only
trust our true inner compass which is
our own heart
and how do we know how to trust our own
heart we have to spend time in communion
with our own life form our own direct
connection to source
and for me and for many of us this will
come in
as a feeling tone in the body so we have
to train ourselves to understand that
just because somebody writes something
or because somebody says something
doesn't make it so and
we are very um we are very
expansive technologies the human being
and we have more senses than five senses
and so this is giving us an opportunity
to really feel into situations
and being in touch with your body gives
you
the connection your supreme intelligence
is in your heart
not in your mind it's not your intellect
it's your feeling
and we're going to have to develop this
ability to trust what is right for us
well that's a practice i mean i think
they're you know and that's
something that you have you know
developed over
many years by virtue of the things that
you do
i feel like most people are pretty
disconnected from who they are
and they're living their lives
reactively and that makes it
makes makes them very prone to
manipulation and just sort of
you know responding to whatever they see
in their twitter feed and then
adopting that philosophy and
regurgitating it
without really spending that time to
you know reflect on the veracity of it
or to
develop that sense of interconnectedness
with oneself to
have the like the acumen to understand
whether that is resonating with you
you know on a on a fundamental very real
way or whether
it's just some idea that you picked up
in the atmosphere somewhere and decided
to repeat
right it's true but we have to begin now
and so
for me these are um what's happening on
the planet are things that i've been
aware of for many years and i've been
the crazy person who
you know has this perspective but the
gift of this is now we can really start
to look at what is
so we can really see that in our society
there are a lot of
forces that are not operating for the
benefit of humanity
they are not what i would call life
affirming
um you know agendas or intentions
and so um it's about reclaiming our own
power
understanding just how powerful the
human being
is who knows itself who actually has a
connection to source
and this goes back to developing a yoga
practice
you know starting to sit with yourself
going off of twitter
you know connecting with nature starting
to feel
how you could cultivate loving
compassion
in every situation how could you start
to perceive
all of life as sacred starting with
yourself
which is very challenging because we
have a lot of judgments about
ourselves our bodies um you know i would
say the internal dialogue
of you know the average human or most
humans
is one of um you know
not kind communication so we're usually
telling our body like
we wish you weren't like that we wish
you were different
you know there's a lot of self-judgment
and so one of the techniques that
you know i use and that i have used and
i use with my clients and my
spiritual community water tiger is we
do mirror work and so you actually sit
in the mirror breathing and gazing into
your eyes and
a lot of stuff comes up when you yeah
you
engage in that practice talked about
that when he was on the podcast
that's like a core aspect of his love
yourself
you know program yeah i think it might
be one of the most powerful
and one of the ones that is the most
confrontational
for most people so to actually
look at what is is a very powerful
practice and technique and in the
beginning you may
feel all kinds of emotions you know a
lot of people cry
they see relatives who have been
deceased
but after a while after you get through
the discomfort
you can start to really look at yourself
in the truth of who you are and start to
receive yourself as sacred as
something that's divine that is alive
for a purpose
and that is loved and valued by creation
you know infinitely and eternally and so
it's
it's a it's a powerful powerful means
and one i recommend and
hopefully everybody listening to this
podcast has a mirror
and you can go meet yourself in the
mirror and what does that practice look
like specifically
well you uh should be in a private area
you know where you can
do yourself public bathrooms no um uh
you know uh sometimes it's good to do it
uh sort of at twilight or where the
light is a little bit lower
um to actually just sit and you would
gaze into the third
eye point between the eyes relaxed
and breathing connected to your breath
and attempt to keep your eyes open
you won't be able to your eyes will burn
and you'll need to blink them
but at least it you know intend to keep
the eyes open and soften the gaze in
that area
and see what comes up for you and so i
recommend starting off with
maybe five minutes and then maybe
increase that to 10 minutes
and maybe journal and really observe
and reflect on the emotions you know
get in touch with how you're feeling
about your physical
so the first stage is really developing
an understanding of
what is looping in your mind right like
first you have to be able to be
objective about what that is before you
can start to deconstruct it and
and you know construct a new narrative
yeah and and also what emotions are you
feeling what does that bring up for you
you know what are the memories or the
feelings or the attitudes or thoughts
that come
up for you when you sit and really
receive yourself
and how does that look there's a kernel
of
zen buddhism to this and by that i mean
the idea that the best way for you
to be a force of positive good in the
world
is to reflect inward and focus on
developing
you know the best version of who you can
possibly be right
how do you square that with
a sense or a call to take a stand
on an issue or a feeling that
you know this is a moment where we can't
be quiet and we need to
uh you know exert ourselves or have our
voices be heard
on some of these issues that culture is
grappling with right now
so those are two different things right
i mean by this practice i'm not
suggesting that we all go
go to the mirror and all of our problems
will be solved and right it's like being
in the cave versus being involved no no
so i think this is a really amazing
opportunity for us to stop
doing this human tendency which wants to
choose
one way so we want to say this or that
what i'm going to say is this time is
asking us to say
yes and both so both
so what these practices do this practice
of mirror gazing or i would highly
recommend a yoga practice
for everyone and anyone in any form you
can get it
the practice of yoga will bring you into
communion with the observer that is
watching you in your life and it will
allow you
to um use the asanas the practices
and also meditation to be in stillness
into this place of neutrality which is
neutral loving compassion
one thing that's confusing for us is a
lot of times when we're a human who is
in the doing
we reflect on the beingness as being
irresponsible or opting out or hiding in
the cave
or unproductive right or unproductive
but what we're saying
is that if you can be in neutral loving
compassion which i always talk about
being the jedi
so you're in the jedi so you're merged
with your awareness of source
but a lot of stuff can be happening from
that state of awareness
so you can go to a protest in that state
of awareness
you can express yourself you can stand
up and speak out for what you
care about but the ground of that
is in a great vast anchoring of
the nature of life the totality of life
and this brings a point that i wanted to
bring up that has really been present
for me
and is present for me in these um
alchemical fire ceremonies that i
light in the middle of the night and
different practices that i engage in
and that is the aspect of the mystery of
life
so we will never know
the totality of life of the choices that
are made
of why certain souls choose different
times to exit
um you know you just never know you and
i are having this
this conversation you know i could leave
my body
after this interview when i'm driving
home we don't know
no one has the capacity to know that and
so for
me there's great power in developing a
reverence for the mystery of life
for understanding that everything is so
fragile it's not
it's not within my personality's choice
to know
what the highest outcome is i can't see
the vast
play from the area of source or the
vantage point of
consciousness so there is a reverence
there's a devotion and there's a giving
over
to that great mystery of life and in
that
devotion and that commitment and
returning to that communication
over and over and over again
it provides a connection to something
that is miraculous
that is beyond the um the solutions that
we
see in our culture today there's always
a wild card
there's always the miracle the
miraculous
and that is what i count on
see what i think i do and what i think
most humans do
is i keep the fear at bay by
trusting in structures and
um deluding myself into this idea that
certain things have a permanence
that they actually don't right like that
we live in a democracy and this is the
way
the world works and this is what i do
and this is where
i fit in and with all of that i feel
safe and i can sleep at night
and what you're suggesting is to
understand
and step into a greater awareness of the
maya of all of that right like these are
all just mental constructs that we
fabricate in our minds to make us feel
okay but in truth
none of them are real they're social
contracts at best
and what we're seeing right now is a
great kind of deconstruction and
dismantling that's
occurring you know in many different
ways all across the globe and that's
fomenting a lot of fear because it's
challenging people's ideas
um around the permanence of things
and the fragility of not just our own
corporal physical bodies with respect
you know vis-a-vis to this virus but the
planet's fragility
in light of you know how humans have
tread on it over the last
couple hundred years um and i think that
that
um puts us all in a delicate headspace
that makes us trigger-happy
when we open up our twitter feeds right
like we're
like ready to pounce because we're not
even consciously aware
of the extent of the kind of fear
that is created by that level of
um uncertainty the growing awareness
around that uncertainty
yeah well i mean what we're really
avoiding is death right i mean
ultimately
it all leads back to fear of death
that's that's
that's where the treasure is right there
and so the best thing that we could do
is go face our death get clear with that
get as close to that as you can
imagine you know what that is face it
sit with it
commune with it and again these
structures are really super helpful and
also
necessary in this life like it wouldn't
be okay if we just ignored what was
going on and laid on the couch and said
well whatever
i don't like seeing humanity suffer i
want us to suffer less i want there to
be more love
in the world i'm going to do everything
that i can
to at least feed the lesser of the evils
to try to break the fall as much as i
can
because i am a modern woman i'm a mother
i'm
a wife i'm i'm a business owner you know
i'm in this world i'm not in a cave on a
mountain i'm here
i'm here in the culture but what i would
say is
that i feel that uh
on social media in the community and
energetically there is an agenda to
separate us and tear us apart
um i have family members that voted for
trump
i am not an advocate of him
or the energy that he represents um
that might get me in trouble on your
show i don't know but i'm
i have no problem saying that people are
gonna come out they're gonna come after
me now
um but what i will say is that i love
these family
members and i have to find a way
to respect their perspective
to meet them in some form of love
some form of kindness some
form of curiosity um so that i can
understand
why they had that perspective um we were
talking about we knew an individual who
became a flat earther and um you know
this individual you know we have known
him to be
a kind and loving and meaningful member
of
you know of community and so while i
don't
adhere to that and that seems rather
ridiculous to me
um why is the response so aggressive
and so um uh canceling it's the canceled
culture you know whatever you say you
know you're afraid to say anything
because if you say something then
somebody will find
some position that then cancels that
perspective
and what i'm saying as a spiritually
devoted person what i know is that life
is diverse
and there are billions of perspectives
not only in our
cultures but in the universes in the
multiverses
and so it's unintelligent to cancel
another perspective that is not a
life-affirming
energy or position or i guess
emotion so what i think would be
very very healing for us as a culture
would be um to be an on wonder
and to ask people how did you get to
that perspective and what are your life
experiences and what what do you fear
and what do you love in life
and what have you suffered from that you
know why did you make that choice
yeah i mean i think the the kind of
compassionate healthy
response to somebody who's offering
you know an opinion or a a world view
with which you disagree with is to say
tell me more right like
you know how can i engage that person
from a perspective of really genuinely
trying to understand
not just that idea but what led them to
that idea
is always a better tactic than attacking
but i think to play devil's advocate a
little bit
because everything feels so fractured
right now there is
um at least and i'm speaking only for
myself
but i'm witnessing this more broadly
there's this
desire to figure out where solid ground
is
and when somebody is you know out there
advocating for something that's so
patently and blatantly and obviously
counter to the truth
the vigorous reaction to that i think
comes from a place of
you know a desire that we need to like
truth matters facts matter
and in this world where everybody's
screaming at each other like it is
important what's real and what isn't and
we need to be able to come together
and agree on a certain you know idea
of realness yeah because otherwise
we're lost but so that's my respect this
is an argument that we've had and you're
like well let's just
everybody has their own everybody's
right from their own perspective and i'm
like
okay but you know the earth is not flat
and so why are we
giving that person as much credence as
the person who says
no the world is not flying well we're
maybe not but you know we shouldn't be
doing that
but maybe we're just not being unkind or
cancelled violent right against that
life
that individual need not be canceled and
eradicated from society
but you know perhaps they could be
better educated maybe
maybe loved into another perspective and
it's kind of it's kind of similar how we
are with plant-based eating
is you know we've created i've created
almost 500 recipes in the plant-based
world and
you know i have a lot of friends that
are not plant-based
and i don't come at them with judgment
or
preaching to them or you know showing
them pictures of violence
um i just be loving and keep cooking
amazing foods
and keep making amazing you know cheese
um so my point is is it's it
it's feeling very much like in our
culture
uh we have different views about
different things and there's a lot of
very
intense things going on right now like
we should all be very
paying attention right now it is not a a
moment to
uh go to sleep right but it's also not a
time to be
reactive and out of balance it's a time
to to really cultivate that inner jedi
warrior well and then
the the danger of that is that we've
gone on social media and posted a bunch
of things and
you know and commented and said all this
stuff and then we
feel within ourselves that we've done
this great you know public service
but the question is have you really you
know like
what is really going on on social media
who are we
actually really connecting with you know
who is agreeing with you do you even
know the quality of that life form that
is agreeing you that
with that thinks you're so amazing and
so it's a very
um kind of crazy um
world that we're in and you and i are
are you know products of that and
you know i have a community a spiritual
community water tiger which i got
completely through social media and we
do have a subscription
community where we go deeper and discuss
these kind of things but
you know overall um you know i have
i'm sure like many like most of us i
have very mixed emotions about
the whole platform of social media and
is it really helping us
i kind of feel like i'm like i'm
gambling and thinking i'm winning and
i'm probably not winning
of course not well we both watched the
the social dilemma and
um you know people that watch or listen
to this podcast know that i just did a
whole podcast with with adam skolnik
where we kind of broke down that movie
and shared our perspectives
but yeah it's uh it's disturbing and
disheartening when
you pull back the curtain and you have a
better understanding of how these
platforms function and
operate the extent to which you know we
are the product and we are being
mined and manipulated to such a vast
extent
and at the same time both you and i have
cultivated and crafted
careers that support our family as a
result of these platforms so it's not
necessarily a black or white thing but
it does
um you know it is you know
that movie has really reshaped the
relationship that i want to have with
these platforms and
you know you've been saying this forever
but um
i'm more mindful of this now than ever
this idea that like when you have an
instinct to share something it's like
okay why
am i doing this for what purpose like
what is the what is the greater good
or what is the aspiration behind doing
this like what is the why behind why you
feel compelled to
put something up on one of these
platforms yeah and i mean i'm
you know maybe i need to be a little bit
more like you because i'm
quite sensitive and you know go into
darkness to find my connection in the
middle of the night and
there's a lot of times i'm supposed to
post content i just can't do it like
it's not in my body i can't
i've tried to get on like a schedule so
that i'm consistent
you know you i've never done you've been
such an amazing consistent but i mean
with your podcast yeah but
now like i really just i use it to share
new episodes of the podcast it's pretty
rare that i use it for anything other
than that
and unless i just feel i wake up and i
feel like oh i have something cool that
might be
helpful that i feel i feel good and i
feel like sharing it but i don't feel
compelled to just be you know sharing my
life
all the time on there it's a change i
mean you were in the early
early days but not now yeah so uh and
the other thing is is it's not just that
we've built
you know a career we have thousands of
people
that we have had deep meaningful life
experiences through so
social media for you and me has not been
a light thing
it's been a very interesting incredible
people as a result of it and a lot of
the guests that i've gotten on the
podcast
i've been able to do that because of
social media yeah
yeah so it's very tricky it's tricky but
i you know i think
now you know that we have a greater
perspective
you know it's up to us to choose to use
the tool
and make sure that we're not being used
by the tool so it's
well we're being used by it we're
definitely being used if you're using it
you're being used by it right that's the
truth right and that's the disturbing
reality
mean the level or the extent right
but i think the pernicious aspect of it
is that
when you think you have a healthy
relationship with it you're still not
fully aware of the extent to which
you're being manipulated and used by it
and that was the real
message of that movie like even if you
think like oh all i do is do this
or i do you know that's not what's going
on
here yeah you know it's a much darker
reality
and the you know i just i know for
myself the solution isn't to just
you know basically delete all my
accounts because
this is how we make a living and
communicate with the world so how do you
do that
in a safer and um healthier way yeah i
don't know i mean a few months ago
i um i hired uh ollie a friend that had
come on a plant power italia retreat and
he's been
creating an online platform for a
subscription that wouldn't be
even part of squarespace it would be its
own sovereign
tech you know technical platform and
that's not a replacement for social
media but
it has been in my awareness of the fact
that
uh there may be a world in not too far
off future
where we have our content on our own
individual platforms
well i'm in the process of putting that
together as well i mean you have water
tiger
i've teased this out i haven't talked
about it at length but
um this fall on an undisclosed date
because we're still building it right
now i'm going to be launching a
subscription service
and a big part of it is for that very
reason like i want to take these
communities
not offline but off of these platforms
where it's a safer
um healthier environment uh for the
people who are interested in
the things that i care about and that i
speak to on the show and beyond
to gather and commune um in a way that
uh where they're where they're you know
they're not being data mined and they're
not being manipulated in that way
yeah we hope so we we hope we could
create that well let's shift gears a
little bit we have a little bit of a
show-and-tell here if you're watching
this on video you can see like all this
plant-based cheese here but before we
even
get into the latest with shrimp i think
one thing that gets lost in your story
as somebody who's been on this podcast a
million times and
is always sharing you know deep thoughts
and you know these spiritual practices
uh is the fact that and you alluded to
it a minute ago the fact that
you're you're like this serial
entrepreneur
and always have been like you're a
business a powerful business woman like
setting aside shrimu which we're going
to get into i mean you had
you know this garment line for years and
years and years like pre-internet where
you were doing direct to consumer before
it was a thing and you had this
robust interior design business like
you've had
a lot of chapters in your business
career that have delivered you to this
place to you know create this new
venture that you're working on right now
so
i thought it would be cool to share that
side of you a little bit because that i
don't know that we've really fully
explored that on the podcast yeah
cool thanks for that um it's kind of uh
interesting to hear you describe me like
that thank you so much
i received that you're a startup founder
i kind of am no i actually
you've had multiple startups my bit my
my main mission
well okay so um rich is going to judge
me because i have a business degree from
an
inferior university
i don't know i agree at all but you you
went to really good schools i went to
arizona state everyone
so hey man and i have a i have this
degree
i actually uh went there because i was
frozen
after having being raised in alaska so i
think i just entered like a certain
climate into this computer and it gave
me these
options and i'm going there yeah dry and
hot yeah i was like i'm going to
where the sun shines every day um and
you know i didn't have good sat scores
or anything like that um so anyway i
went to arizona state i had never been
to arizona
and uh within that four-year period i
also lived in france for six months
which was a phenomenal experience where
i
learned to speak french fluently and and
created a whole community there that was
amazing
but i came back and graduated from
business school with a degree in
international marketing
um and the crazy thing is is that my mom
um so she's from chile
and um she uh was from a sort of high
society
uh part of life there and
her father left her mother when she was
16 years old
and so she and he was a healer like i
was and moved to the south and spent his
days out
actually as a healer he was very much
like me
and i never met him but she would always
tell me
my father would have loved you like
we're very alike
his name was ernesto so uh
so my mom really wanted me to have
business nailed
um she and my dad ended up um
stability yeah then instability in the
fact you know she then supported her mom
and her sister
and she spoke english quite well and she
became a secretary um
and then that's how she ended up meeting
my dad eventually and
they moved to the united states he was a
texan who was down mapping the jungles
he was mapping the jungles of the amazon
my mother was engaged to
an american engineer and
this engineer drowned uh a month before
their wedding
and my father was his replacement it's a
crazy story crazy story like
somebody's gotta make a movie about it
someday um but
he's a bush pilot hunter
fisherman from amarillo texas so it's
very much a green acres thing like he
meets this
kind of high society chilean woman and
takes her back
did they go back to texas first or
colorado they went to texas first and
like
there was a big article about my mom in
the paper because she was like the first
exotic creature yeah exotic creature
that had arrived it was sort of like you
know they'd found the dinosaur bones or
whatever
um yeah then they moved to colorado and
she gave birth to five children i'm her
youngest
and i'm named for her mother and so i'm
julie rosado
named after julia rosado and your mom
had a dress shop
for years and years and years in
anchorage right is that where you first
learned business
yeah um so i i went to east anchorage
high school
[Laughter]
and my mom had a dress shop and i was
way overdressed
um every day of high school because i
would just open the boxes up and take
like the best looking thing that
happened to be
there um so i worked with her and i
would go on buying trips with her to la
and um and she really wanted me to learn
business and when i got my
high school transcripts i always took
like business law
or real estate law like take that in
high school
i didn't have classes like that in high
school anchorage high was really amazing
you should have seen what was history
wow that's quite something
so um so when i went i realized from my
high school transcripts i had only ever
taken one art class
and that was like ceramics and drawing
when i was in junior high
and i i won an award for this very not
that amazing thing that i did
um and then i didn't pick up an art tool
again
until i was like 20 in my late 20s
i had become so i went to arizona state
lived in paris
then graduated and my sister was working
in the garment business my sister vic
in la and i didn't know what i was going
to do but i had no intention of going to
la
and she introduced me to this guy named
michael bush
and he was a garment sales person
and he interviewed me and hired me so i
came to la
and went right to downtown to l.a martin
started working and he taught me how to
sell
he said this is what you do you show the
line and then you
you look at the buyer and you say can i
have the paper
you know it was like you asked them very
directly for the papers so i said okay
so we had this show and i did exactly
what he asked me to do
and i handed him like a hundred thousand
dollars worth of business
and he was like what did you just do and
i was like well i just do what you asked
me to do
and so instantly a salesperson was born
and i ended up having this amazing
experience in garments
um i worked for the notorious allen
schwartz who owned abs which are some of
the most hilarious
and um he's like king of the knockoffs
yeah and yeah quite quite an
extraordinary eccentric person
um but uh you know much
uh sexual harassment and things going on
during those years
like if if that was happening yeah i
mean the me too aspect
of the world i could have sued so many
people
i mean i was locked in my showroom at
different times not by allen this was
a different a different boss but anyway
so i
ended up becoming the west coast sales
manager for shelly siegel
who's an amazing um designer lovely
lovely human being she's do you remember
the actor robbie benson
yeah that's her that's his sister so she
was quite talented
she um designed a line called laundry
and shelley used to invite me in to edit
her line she wouldn't let anybody else
in
and so in my late 20s i decided to go
back to
fashion design school as a professional
and i got my
fashion design degree in a year and i
picked up a pencil and discovered that i
had a natural talent for drawing
that i never knew and i was so bummed
because i felt like i spent all of these
years of my life
not developing what i'm made to do but
in the end it worked out because i had
both
business and creative i was able to get
up to speed creatively
you know quit more quickly um
so i created my own fashion line and i
took it to imagnan and sold it and got
on the cover of their christmas catalog
and that launched my collection
julie pilot collection julie piet
collection right and it hung in bridge
and i
was hanging what does that mean bridge
oh it's you know it's lingo
for you know being in the garment
industry it's basically like it's
it's not super cheap but it's not
designer it's like a bridge line so it's
between
and i hung with lines like anna suey
mark eisen
dk calvin klein which is called ck
so i was in this really beautiful
section and
like everything which is kind of cool
that you're asking me about this
is when i create something i usually do
it pretty
luxuriously and so rather than starting
with a t-shirt
or something that was simple i designed
36-piece
jackets with like crystal buttons from
austria
so when you're making that in la there
are like 12 subcontractors that have to
touch that jacket
before it emerges and so it was a very
complex business that i ended up going
into
um well the hilarious thing i mean first
of all it
it's worth saying like everyone knows
you as like this cookbook author
and this person who's created you know
all these recipes but
you know it's fascinating to hear that
the roots of this are in a
completely different industry and you've
told stories over the years of just how
insane
the fashion industry is like no other
business
would function the way that this
functions like you would come up with
this design and you'd create the pattern
and then you take it to these various
subcontractors and say this is how i
want it this is how you sew it this is
how it goes
and then they would just return it to
you completely different like if you say
i want a
they just give you z and then they look
at you blankly like what are you and
you're like this is not what i ordered
and they're like well this is what it is
oh it's highly complex i mean you can't
even do that first of all you're a small
manufacturer
and so they're selling uh companies that
are massive so you have to go in and
develop a personal relationship with the
subs
to somehow convince them to show to sow
yourself because you're it's just not
worth it it's not worth it yeah
so it's all personal and if you leave
them i remember the first time like i
lied to the buyer at imagine and told
her that i was like
had full production facilities i'd never
produced one thing in my entire life
so i had the order which was a good
problem to have
and they don't pay you ahead of time
right like they're like we want this
many of this
and then it's on you to go and create it
yeah it should
pay you until way later if at all
actually if they pay you
if they pay you that's the other thing
like they don't even pay you
no it's crazy and you know you have to
watch it every step of the way i
remember being in south central and
dropping off my first
lot and i was just driving away hoping
like i hope this place doesn't start on
fire
like it's there in the morning and you
have to check in with them because
you know if they're sewing a thousand
blouses and they're sewing the left
blouse
the left sleeve to the right armhole
like that's a big problem
so you you have to catch it before so
there's a lot
there's so much that goes into garment
production especially when you're a
small
person a small manufacturer i learned
so much from that experience and i was
basically me
and one part-time employee who was my
pattern maker
um it was it was a lot of work that i
put in yeah
and you were in you were in some of the
other stores too not just imag
no i was in all the bridge source so i
was in fred siegel
nordstrom barney's macy's
um bergdorf goodman i magnum
sax like i was legit but it's a classic
example
like you have this idea like oh well if
you're in all these stores you must be
crushing it
right and meanwhile you're like dying no
it took me six years
actually to learn that all the guys all
the men that came to work in ferraris
were leveraged to the to the hill like
they actually didn't have the money to
own that ferrari
it's because it's all lifestyle
presentation yeah
it's all like um yeah smoke and mirrors
sort of type thing and i mean some
people really hit it big but you got to
stay in
you know go to being and relentless and
it never stops
like even everything's old the minute
you put in the showroom it's old
so you have to go right back to the
design board and it's this very manic
um relentless you know pressure
remember to be innovative i remember
years and years ago there was a
documentary
about isaac mizrahi do you remember that
i think and that was my introduction to
kind of a glimpse behind
the scenes of what the fashion industry
is really like and
what i recall it was so long ago but i i
do remember
being amazed at how manic it was and
like you just can't breathe for a second
because you're always the next line and
the next line and it always has to be
different and different and different
and it's incredible that
anybody succeeds because it's just a
recipe for burnout
right and the other thing i think is
unique that's unique to this business
and correct me if i'm wrong is that
in most businesses you can kind of just
grow slowly and organically you know
just like every year a little bit better
a little bit better but
in fashion you can take your line to a
certain point
but you're just going to be starving in
manic
forever unless you get a massive
infusion of capital
to then get over the hump and become
like a tommy hilfiger right like
that doesn't happen by increments it it
only happens with like gigantic cash
infusion so it's the only way that you
can
grow it really is it's it's very very
treacherous and
and and requires more energy more
consistent energy
and sort of this relentless mania
in order to get to that place and the
reason that i made a decision to close
my company
well let's before we even get to that
you make this pivot
to doing it direct to concern yeah let's
talk about that because that's
i think that informs the sensibility
behind shrimu also like pre-internet
you know you just decide i'm gonna i'm
gonna circumvent
all these stores and i'm just gonna go
right to the customer
and how do you even do that in in an era
when it's all about retail
yeah it was so interesting so i just
what happened is during
okay so i was doing julie pie collection
and selling all those stores and
then uh priscilla presley came to me
which is another part of my history a
friend of mine was saying like i hope
you're putting this in your book like i
almost forget
priscilla came to me um through another
producer that i knew and
she asked me to co-design a line with
her for home
shopping network and i really like
priscilla a lot she's quite a beautiful
woman
and um i really really enjoyed her
and so i was like okay this is a great
opportunity you know and i spent
six months with her and so we worked
together
uh diligently for about a six-month
period and the contracts were being
drawn up
and the night before i was supposed to
sign the contract i started vomiting
and everything in my body was like you
cannot do this
agree this arrangement and i called her
at home and told her that i
was unable to sign the um and the reason
was the resistance was what the
resistance was is that she was this
celebrity
and i was doing all the work it was
basically like i was gonna have to bleed
like we just talked about right
and she was going to get all the credit
and she also had a manager that would
brief me on how i should speak to her so
like every time i would talk to her he
would call me and say
don't like don't talk about it like that
say it like this and i was young and
fiery and it just really made me angry
that he would talk to me like that
and um i just was like it was more like
that thing that i was talking about in
the beginning it was in my body
like my mind didn't know because who
wouldn't want to be partners with
priscilla presley and i liked her
a lot so my body finally got to this
point was like uh uh
you cannot do this it's almost like if i
had done it it would have made me sick
and when i called her to tell her she
was just like no no julie like we can
work it out we can work it out and i was
like
i said to her i said i'm an artist like
i'm not interested in doing
a line that you have your name on i'm
like i'm the one that's going to be
bleeding
that's going to be doing all this work i
was like i want to do it for me
and so i gave her my line free i said
take the line i don't want anything
does she end up selling she went on air
she went on air
she did she went on air once and then
that she never did it anymore and i ran
into her recently at the humane society
well some years ago
and i was able to go up and say hi to
her i was like do you remember me and
she was like yes i remember
so it was sweet to see her yeah so how
does that then
translate into this pivot this like this
trunk show thing that you started with
okay so if you're in stores um
it's a big uh markdown dance
so in fact you're paying once you get a
once you get your foot in the door and
you're sort of in the department
then it becomes like if they don't sell
enough then they hit you back with what
you didn't sell
so it's this really deal with the devil
like it's never clear it's never
fair and you're always at the
um like leasing a car or going into the
casino like it's all it's stacked
against you're paying for shelf space
and then you're paying
you know it's just it sort of feels like
you can not find any way out of it and
at the time
you know and and still today i had a
really strong network
of people that i'm connected with and
they
loved my stuff and so i had this crazy
idea i was like what if i call
my six best friends in these major
cities around the country
i'll ask them to bring 50 people to
their homes
i'll get a model i'll do a size range of
muslins
and i'll fly in and do a presentation
and i'll charge them a hundred percent
of the order up front
and i'll drop ship it to their offices
12 weeks later
what's interesting about that is that it
sounds like an idea that would work now
but at the time that just was insane
nobody was doing that
and i'm sure everybody told you nobody's
going to pay for that nobody's going to
do that
yeah i don't even know i mean i i had
this beautiful um
southern model named nancy green and um
i i did this whole presentation that
included a video of i love lucy
modeling in paris i can't remember
exactly what my shtick was but
i opened up the evening with these 50
women
showing them this video and then talking
about
you know fashion and uh it worked
actually quite well
um i sold i had no problem selling in
advance 12 weeks
in advance um my issue was when i got
back from this world tour this
this uh how many cities did you get i
did like
i did like six cities total like i
worked so hard and i was pregnant with
trapper at the time so i was a pregnant
woman
basically doing and had a one-year-old
at home
so um i remember i would come home
after working and like take a bath and
just have to breathe to get myself
back into the energy because i would go
out in the evening and do these trunk
shows
because i had to then i produced the
stop
the inventory and i had to sell into it
and it was just me
so it was an extreme amount of effort
um what i didn't factor in is that it
would take me
i had now a thousand orders to process
where otherwise you would get like one
sheet of order with a bunch of
styles right and the other thing i
realized is that i lost all of my
profit in the extra sizes that nobody
bought so like you get the person and
they're like you know i want the pant in
a 12 in pink
and as a designer you're like thinking
you're not going to wear that pant in
pink you know
what i should have said is you're
forbidden to wear that pant in pink but
i didn't
so what happens is you try to produce
for everybody and then you
lose the the profit is in just those
right because unless you're doing it at
some level of scale
when you're doing one-offs you're never
going to get out for money and i did
everything from t-shirts to evening
gowns
and fake fur jackets i would go to lax
in my jeep
and pick up fake fur from germany and
drive it on the roof
of my car to the studio like
the amount of commitment that it takes
to do that it's
you have to be young and insane and the
reason that i ended up
so anyway i did that for about a year
and then i burnt out
and i read calvin klein's autobiography
and donna karen's autobiography and i
realized that this was never
going to stop that there was it doesn't
matter how big you get or how successful
it's still like this crazy manic
exactly and i was like i can't and
i had been picked up by a very reputable
accounting firm who was
supposed to be guiding me and i had done
a big fashion show at the pacific design
center and i had over a hundred styles
in that show
i had by the way i had women from the
real estate community that i knew
modeling for me
i had some professional models but i
also brought real people
into the show and it was this beautiful
night and i remember my father's jaw was
on the floor he
couldn't believe that i had done all of
that one of the times that he was so
proud of me
but i was pregnant with trapper and i
walked out on the runway at the end with
tyler in my arms and trapper in my belly
and i had just managed this like
herculean thing
and so after um trapper was born um
you know i don't know maybe six months
after he was born i made the decision to
close the company
because i was like i just can't do it
and i was
heartbroken literally
i was i got sick for like four weeks
and um i i had left with like a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars debt
like when the train stops and everything
hits the wall and the whole thing it all
catches up with you
and i was so unseasoned in business
that i took that so personally that i
couldn't repay
some of those things and i would go see
my subs and they would say julie it's
okay like
this is business you're gonna be back
like it's fine but it literally was like
um really um soul-crushing
so when you look back on that do you
have any
regrets do you ever imagine what it
would have been like
like let's say somebody did come in and
say here's
you know i love what you're doing you
just need structure and you need help
like here's
x number of dollars to get you rolling
and hire
staff and create some infrastructure
here
yeah i mean i was a prolific designer
literally never out of creative ideas
and my line is beautiful when i look at
photos today it's still beautiful
it's not like it was a fad it just
wasn't meant to be
and i guess the silver lining for me is
that when i did close the company and
went through like a four-week collapse
after that i found yoga and i started
practicing yoga
even though i was i was still
spiritually connected because we were
following deepak chopra's seven laws of
spiritual success
like i had my team and my people we were
always inspiring them
in that kind of way like a you know
altruistic living
and you did tony robbins a bunch of
times oh yeah i did tony robbins during
i did all tony robbins um programs all
the mastery
financial mastery unleashed the giant
within
whatever it is i fire walked with him i
fire watch with him totally
um it was great my partner in those was
uh chuck norris's
um sidekick on the show his name's is
his name clarence
i don't remember anyway super fun he was
my partner in one of the advanced
um you know programs so it was really it
was really cool but literally broke my
heart
after that i built uh i became a house
contractor
and i built um a home that overlooks all
of malibu that's the highest
point that was the home that i had with
the boy's dad
and then after that i built the home
that you and i are in now
so um and everybody was like oh building
isn't that stressful i was like no
it's just one house it's not ten
thousand sleeves
so i had you know the idea that building
a house would be simpler
than manufacturing a line of clothing
way simpler
ironic and way way way simpler and and i
love it and
and uh if anybody gets a chance to do
that it's it's a
wonderful wonderful experience i i
really loved it well i think what's
great about
those stories that you just shared is
that they all inform
kind of what you're doing now and people
will look at you and say oh
now she's the doyan of you know vegan
cheese but
look what backed it up like there's a
whole career
decades of you know experience that you
garnered
you know doing difficult things in the
business world and succeeding and
failing
and trying again so when you look back
when you reflect on
those experiences you know what did you
learn that has informed
your approach to you know shrimu and
what you're doing now
well i mean i think what i've learned is
that
you know in order to create something
that's very powerful
the vision has to be very unified like
very very true
and very very real
so i knew when i was creating shrimu
um it was sort of had to be this
expression of
beautiful design highest quality
um purest ingredients and really done
in the way where it's i consider
shreemu to be a beauty brand we we
haven't seen it there's more
going to be coming cheese is leading but
it's really a beauty a beauty brand
i'm offering shreemu as an invitation to
a beautiful life
and that beautiful life comes from uh
eating a high vibrational uh not cheese
product
which i call the next evolution of
cheese so i'm not asking
us to give up our love of cheese i've
just made it better
so it's better for our health our bodies
it's better for the animals
it's better for the planet and it's
ultimately better for our children
and so um for me uh you know meeting
brian ahara
who is uh the amazing artist who um did
this coding which i have these
these tattoos go out with shreemu right
shipments
um and this coding brian has written
backwards
and read backwards his entire life and
so he developed this
branding for me this says devotional
offering this is what is within this
coding
um and it's part of my my label and my
brand and
and and so i guess for me it's like i
had to start at the
peak of the artistic expression um
knowing that
this is a global brand and i have
over 40 recipes of cheese where i can
tell you
anyone that ate them would be you know
falling on the floor in ecstasy or being
very excited about the flavors
but shrimu now is at the top of that
and then you know as i go there will be
more mass products and you know there's
many more
aspects of the business in the vision so
perhaps i'm overestimating how
aware the audience is about what you are
doing at the moment
probably is worth providing a little bit
of background
so you uh co-authored a couple cookbooks
with me which were really your cookbooks
like my name is
let's just be honest you know if we're
being honest like you
in solidarity with my decision to go
plant-based and trained for these races
you showed up and infused our kitchen
with a tremendous amount of creativity
to
initially to support me but then it
became its own creative inspiration for
you
the result of that is everything that
we've co-created together including
the plant power whey cookbook the plant
power whey italia cookbook which is a
nod to the retreats that we do where we
take these groups of people to this
beautiful
agriturismo in tuscany and have a
seven-day experience of
food and meditation and community and
in addition to that you authored another
book called this cheese's nuts you
became obsessed with trying to figure
out
how to create plant-based cheese and
this was many years ago this wasn't
yesterday and you basically went into
the kitchen
treated it like a lab and set about
cracking the code on trying to create
like the next evolution the next
level of what a plant-based cheese could
taste like because at the time
there are plenty of brands in the store
most of them not so good
most of them taste kind of the same
relatively bland
and you thought there's got to be a
better way to do this
and over many years and a lot of
experimentation
you really figured i i have to say like
you completely figured it out and you
created this book which basically
tells people how to do this themselves
at home you continue to iterate and
learn and experiment
and grow and then it got to this place
where
people were like well i love the book
but you know i'm just never gonna do
this at home like can you just make
cause you would make it and we would
bring it to dinner parties or we would
share it with friends and people would
just
flip out like they would just lose their
minds they just couldn't believe that
there wasn't dairy in this cheese
because this isn't just this isn't like
american slices of cheese this is
like high-end very fine artisanal wheels
of cheese that are reminiscent of
you know the the the parisian flavors
that you're so familiar with whether
it's a brie or a camembert or
you know those kind of exotic very
cheesy
iterations of cheese and people would
say like
just can you just make like i'll buy it
like i'm never gonna i'm too busy i'm
not gonna make this will you just make
it
and you were like i'm not gonna do that
but then you know it dawned on you at
some point i'm interested in what that
point was where you just decided okay
maybe
i can do this and so you set about like
creating this line of cheese called
srimu
which is now a full-fledged startup
we're going to get into what's happening
currently with it but you've turned it
into
this really beautiful direct-to-consumer
product line yeah so
yeah thanks i mean it took first of all
i mean i have
friends of mine that live in paris half
the time lucy and jan uh welters
and uh he's a fashion photographer she's
a stylist and
you know they eat french cheese like as
they speak french their kids speak
french like they live in paris half the
time and they were
freaking out over my cheese so they
would just be
you know inhaling it saying you have to
make this you have to make this and
you know i i took a long time you know i
have to say
i had a lot of pain over what i
attempted or what i experienced with
julie paya collection and i was like i
know what production is
i'm not at a loss at what that is
and i started to sort of meditate on
what it would take to launch
this food company and quite frankly
it's a lot simpler it's a lot more
direct
and it has a greater capacity to make a
global impa
impact that will be a legacy for me i
mean something that would
actually transform people's lives from
within their kitchens and i've done that
with my cookbooks and
you know i know that food is an energy
recipes are an energy and i believe that
when i infuse these recipes with my
love of source connection that this
somehow makes it
into whoever is eating the food and so
with shrimpu the vision was to make a
beautiful brand
that was crafted in devotion with the
best ingredients and was made with the
purest
intentions so truly truly made
for the purpose of uh supporting
animals supporting creating more love on
the earth
supporting our bodies i'm a very
i have a very sensitive stomach i can't
eat dairy
i can't eat a handful of nuts
i mean i can eat dairy but i have a
stomachache after so to be clear
um you know before when i wasn't vegan
um but even if i eat a handful of nuts i
have a stomachache right away
so working with these cheeses and curing
them and soaking them and adding the
cultures
and processing them i never had a
stomachache any of the time
and i was absolutely stunned
at the quality of cheese experience that
i've been able to create
and the reason i think that i was able
to create it is that i literally
worked on my own um in a
in an experience of exploration
and i just went for it and tried things
um there were a lot of fails uh before
i figured it out but i've really figured
it out
yeah well a couple things the first
thing is
there were a lot of people who said well
why don't you just go to the farmer's
market
and set up your booth and like sell it
and you're like i'm not doing that like
i did
you know i did a version of that when i
had my fashion line i'm not interested
in that i'm only interested in creating
something
that i can scale and secondarily
uh there's this idea when you when you
raise the issue of like a plant-based
cheese people immediately think fake
cheese and their mind turns to
all these you know processed chemicals
that
a lot of these companies use as binders
to create the flavor
and the texture that people are used to
with cheese right and that's like a
hurdle that you've had to
address and overcome because there is
none of that in in what you do i mean
there's actually very few ingredients
in this product yeah they're very pure
this is not a gooey creepy
vegan cheese that tastes horrible that
you want to
gag it's um it's very pure and authentic
and i think if i
you know what i've learned as a designer
you you know you asked what did you
learn well i think what we learn as
designers or
painters or fashion designers or writers
is you get to a level of maturity where
you understand that less is more
in fact it's the simplicity that makes
something extraordinary
and so if my recipes stand for anything
they stand for the ability to be
simply showcasing what mother nature
provides
with some alchemy and design and flair
and
you know and definitely taste um
but it's really in the simplicity of of
what is done and trying to preserve
um purity in in the product yeah
so one of the things that really struck
me about this journey that you've been
on
is that you really took your time like
you for
months and months and months were in
this incubation phase
where i would be like are you ever gonna
like introduce this to the world
but you were very patient like you
really wanted to be sure about the name
and you know what was the mission
statement and how are you going to
package these things and what recipes
were you going gonna lead with and to me
i just thought just make a decision and
and start doing this like what are you
waiting for
now i see in retrospect that paying off
because the level of like care and
intentionality
that you invested in making sure that
you were making
those decisions correctly for you and
what
you really want like i guess what i'm
saying is you were like i could do it
many different ways but i don't want to
look back on this five years from now
and say
why did i do it this way i should have
done it this way because
and i think i would you know i'm
projecting but i would suspect
a lot of that was informed by not
wanting to end up where you ended up
with julie pie
collection where you were in this manic
thing and not enjoying your life
yeah definitely i mean it's not lost on
me what production entails
and you know the other thing is the
amount of waste that is incurred during
fashion
production and so i had to think
and really meditate on this long and
hard whether i really wanted to step
into this
space and i would say the driving factor
that really
really made the decision for me is the
opportunity that i have to make a global
impact
and i saw how food transforms our lives
you know when people are cooking out of
our cookbooks
we're literally living in their kitchens
they're eating the same food
and food is is also a ritual
it's also a ceremony and so i really
truly
know that all of the intentions
and hopes and dreams and visions that i
have for humanity
for the earth for the animals are really
in these cheeses
it's really true for me had i not
had that spiritual aspect i would have
never done it
i don't need to just do a business to
feel you know to see my name on a label
this is truly a mission for me
and you know in my experience
because i'm an artist i i
needed for my own alignment to start
with a product that was at the pinnacle
of what i could do so i wanted to create
the most extraordinary that i
that i could knowing that there will be
future sub lines
you know the world is vast and there's
you know i have a
velveeta substitute that will just slay
i mean it's amazing so if i can go all
the way
in the different levels and fully intend
to and already have all those recipes
proven and tested
yeah but you come out of the gate with
the highest of the high end
it's the it's the tesla model like elon
musk first introduces
this like lotus you know car that was
like i think it was like 250
000 that first car that tesla came out
with
but the idea was you come out with that
and then each iteration
you start to work your way down until
you get to scale
and are able to produce something that's
widely affordable
but it's that same idea like you set you
set the brand
tone with the highest caliber version of
what you can possibly produce
definitely and also just for me as a as
a being
as an artist i had to do it this way
and um the only thing that's different
is that
unlike tesla i didn't have a financial
team on board
so basically what i did is i guessed at
what the box was going to cost me to
produce having never
had a production kitchen or a paid
workers comp or before we even get to
that
what was the decision walk me through
the decision
to make this a direct to consumer
product rather than taking it to
the supermarkets i think it is informed
by my
experience of fashion of not wanting to
be
in a markdown paid shelf space
experience 20 middlemen yeah with 20.
taking a cut
exactly and also um the other thing that
i really
cherish is the communication with the
community
so the ability to actually um speak to
global issues speak to spiritual issues
speak to health issues and have a
dialogue you know with this group of
people
so for me it's about sort of calling all
these souls together
so that we can collect our energies and
then
all go out and make a better world
create a brighter world
so it was really that community aspect
the community aspect around food
that really informed my decision to
go subscription with this product right
so you make these
top-level decisions you're able to raise
like an angel round of funding to get
you
up on your feet and rolling you
get into a commercial kitchen space in
downtown los angeles you hire a bunch of
people and you're rocking and rolling
and you're starting to build your
subscription base and make a name for
yourself and then
boom pandemic
yeah so how has how has this
experience impacted you as a business
person and how you're
trying to um you know
manage throughout all of this yeah it's
been
challenging and i'm extremely blessed
that we are an essential business
because we are a food business and uh
also we are
um perfectly positioned for
home delivery to actually offer this
cheese experience
into people's individual homes or into
their safe community bubbles
so as a category
i see it as an opportunity of course we
experienced shipping failure
with ups and fedex
with them not guaranteeing shipments at
all
and then they failed to ship um
over three months 20 of our shipments
the shipping has just been
insane it's been insane trying to figure
out how to untie that
right and of course uh because i created
this
you know high-end box that weighs quite
a lot
and one one thing i did do right is
you know i chose the box size and
after a lot of research and going back
and analyzing the size i really
chose the right size like there isn't a
different configuration that would have
made it
cheaper it's all about scale really
and also packing
products that actually keep can keep the
product colder for a longer period of
time
so during covid we've been shipping
literally overnight
to make sure that people receive their
shipments because it's just been about
making sure they receive
um so you know
going forward we have different packing
rating materials that keep the package
cold for three to four days
so that changes a lot for us but one
thing that i want to share is
i found out i hired a financial analyst
so what i did is i was already in this
process before covid hit
doing a lot of research meeting with
every cert every single expert and
you know genius that i know um just
getting people's feedbacks on financial
decks and on strategies and
and these type of things and then covet
hit and i hired a financial analyst
and we've spent all these months going
through every single
cent every line item every process
um and what we discovered is that i was
under charging for my
box so for the um sacred altar box i was
charging 130
just because i was like well that you
know i kind of did it on a paper and was
like maybe that
maybe that's the price um and what we've
discovered looking at the margins and
everything else is that that box is
actually 174 dollars
so um i want to mention that anybody
that has a current existing subscription
of shrimu
and has supported me we are going to
grandfather those
those rates in for you um as long as you
keep your subscription
uh current uh but then i moved to i
i wanted to offer uh some more products
so what i did is i created a four-wheel
box
and then a three-wheel box and
uh you don't get the fresh flavors so um
there were there's fresh mozzarella that
comes in a jar that's
in the baked box in in the big box in
water and then there's the smoked almond
cheddar which is this
not your grandma's cheese ball it's like
insanely good
but the wheels um you can get in the
three
the three wheel or the four wheel and so
we're very
excited we're actually launching with a
three and four wheel
um the three wheel is 88 and the four
wheel is 117
and um um and i've got two new flavors
um also that i've so we have a little we
have like a show-and-tell
should i go around yeah why don't you do
that now
this mic um if you're not watching it on
youtube and you're listening dial up to
youtube
so you can see the presentation of all
these crazy cheeses here but
it's not what you would imagine or
suspect when you think about plant-based
cheese i can tell you that
yeah so so what do we have okay so what
we have on the board here
we have four wheels and we have our
bonfire so
uh we have this is not your grandma's
cheese
yeah it's called bonfire it's a smoky
almond cheddar
absolutely delicious appetizer and you
can also
put it into tacos
it also makes really beautiful little
you can
form it into little no meat balls and
add them to your pasta
it's um irresistibly delicious in every
way and it's shipped in this beautiful
cheesecloth inside a jar
then over here we have one of our new
flavors it's called dolce vita
and this is inspired by gorgonzola
dolce and the blue is actually an
antioxidant
of blueberry which just makes the
beautiful pattern
this is our creamiest cheese
it's made with coconut and cashews
and tastes very cheesy not sweet like
coconut but it gives it that kind of
creaminess
then we have our sort of hero of the
cheese board which
is called birdie it's camembert inspired
this is like the french you know truffle
infused
uh taste of the bistro that we all love
as
cheese lovers and then we have
also spire which is inspired by blue
cheese but it's way better than blue
cheese
and the blue is from spirulina
so um the modeling yeah the modeling and
each one is done by hand so it's a work
of art
and we're really really loving the way
the cheeses are coming out
and then we have this really
extraordinary flavor called gold alchemy
it's a turmeric black pepper and smoky
infused
cashew wheel and this is where that
extra something the mystery of life has
come through the flavors because
when i formulated it um i had my
flowmasters
and a management team come over and i
was like you guys have to taste my new
flavors
and becca took a bite of this and she
was just like
it's so nostalgic it's so nostalgic and
what we determined is that this flavor
tastes exactly like ham cheese
and mustard it tastes the craziest thing
is
you'll taste it i can verify this 110
you'll taste it and you'll be like
that's delicious what does that taste
like like you can't identify it and then
when you say that it clicks in and
you're like oh my god
it taste to me it tastes exactly like
ham and cheese with like mayo and a
little mustard on white bread
like that sandwich that your mom would
make you you know when you were in
elementary school
yeah and like how did that happen i
don't really know it's the weirdest
thing because it's made with
turmeric and cashews yeah it shouldn't
taste like that at
all the ingredients don't line up and i
certainly didn't say oh i'm missing ham
you know let's make that but again this
is that part of life and creativity of
the unseen
it's being devoted to the unseen and i
fully believe
that there are nature elements that are
part of this where you could try to copy
this
like or make it at home it's not going
to be the same
it's just not going to be and this is
sort of like where the sum of the parts
are greater than what is in the recipe
so i'm really really excited to share
that with you guys so
i wanted to just show you so this is the
existing altar box
it's in this beautiful reusable it says
shreemu do life which is devotional
offerings for life
and it's an invitation to a beautiful
life
and here we have brian's um coating here
and then here we have four wheels and
then
in this one so in the ultra box we have
we're going to do um spire dolce vita
birdie and gold alchemy so those are the
they're static we don't have the
capacity to pull one of those out and
show people what it looks like when you
yeah i can go so this one is
spot spire right that's my favorite
right so it comes like that
um and then you have two jars and this
is what the bonfire comes in
and the um the cloud nine clouds
fresh mozzarella which is quite amazing
it's wet and it comes in uh salted
waters and it makes a caprese
and it makes um a beautiful
cream cheese as well so it's quite
awesome
now this box the insert comes out
and you can use this box for all kinds
of things
for sacred tea as a sacred altar box
a lingerie box many things that's what i
use it for
rich puts so here's the smaller one too
yeah so these are the three and four
wheel
so you see they're these amazing box and
this is a very heavy box
so these cheeses are legit so you're
getting quite
um quite an amazing authentic serving so
this is four wheel
so in the four wheel we're doing uh
bertie which is the camembert
we're doing uh gold alchemy which is the
ham and cheese
we're doing a dolce which is the new
coconut
with blueberry antioxidants and spire
and then it's the same box but it has an
insert
in it and it's just oops it's just a
three wheel
so here we have gold alchemy we have
spire and we have elder
and elder is not on this board it's um
a lot like brie and it's really good to
use in cheesecakes as well
and on our website we have quite an
array of recipes that you can
use these cheeses in and i'm very
blessed with my team
i have amazing managers uh becca reiff
and chloe stein who are both vegan chefs
and also
aaron o'neal who is also a chef as well
and so um and the boys tyler and trapper
are working in the kitchen
yeah so our sacred makers are now our
boys slide back over there
harry um well
it's really cool um to see this
happening
um and i know it's just the start
but i can't imagine a better time for
like your timing is incredible like
there could not be a better time for
something like
this there was just an article in
bloomberg i think it was yesterday or
the day before
and it was a long article about just the
ascendancy of the plant-based milk space
and
the kind of vegan plant-based
alternatives to dairy products
in general and it had all these graphs
and you can just see the skyrocketing
you know
consumer markets exploding for this kind
of thing
den own just spent 10 billion dollars in
2017 to buy to buy
white wave which is a plant-based
company like the business aspect of this
is bananas right now and it's been
interesting to see
the dairy industry kind of like dig its
heels in
uh resisting you know what is inevitable
at this point
as people become more and more
interested in getting off you know
lactose-based products
uh and i know you ran into this a little
bit just in figuring out your labeling
like you can't call it cheese and
you know don't use this and you can't
say that and
you kind of steered completely clear of
all of that by coming up with these
unique names that
are not wed to any kind of food at all
but didn't you have like didn't what
didn't like the health department came
by and got
said you can't use this on your label or
something no we were in
for quite a while they were withholding
um our retail permit actually i want to
announce that we
are going to be going into erwin markets
when is that happening it's happening
soon i'm just waiting for this custom
cheese paper because i need messaging to
communicate
because these wheels have authentic
cheese cultures in them and they will
continue to age in your refrigerator and
so they
may develop traces of a white rind and
this is
completely safe to eat it's part of the
process
and that i can communicate to my
subscribers but if it's in the store
i can't so i have the special messaging
that's going on that packaging but we'll
be going in all five stores
are all air ones in southern california
they're all in southern california yeah
right now um so we're gonna be going in
all those five stores
they are air one is sort of the
highest standard of of health food
market
that exists in the country i'm honored
to be collaborating with them and i'm
hoping for
you know a long alliance um to actually
introduce people to shrimu of course
it's a limited selection in erwan
so you can't get everything that you get
in our subscription there
um so they'll they'll only have three
flavors of the wheels
for now but um anyway so
we did finally get our permit we were
able to
create the label that i wanted to and
actually want to thank
um good food institute and bruce for
helping
with that yeah helping me and being you
know just super
supportive um and now the thing that i'm
a little challenged with is
the rates that i'm having to pay for
workers comp
they are making me categorize as a dairy
company
and so that's also one of the challenges
of of small business
which is so crazy like they're like i'm
not using any dairy
it's those they're speaking out of both
sides of their mouth because on the one
hand they're like you can't call it
cheese you can't say that you can't have
a picture of a cow you can't do any of
this stuff
but you're a dairy company and so you're
gonna have to adhere to all these
strict requirements that are
are really just about you know keeping
things safe because there is
you know because dairy uh decomposes in
a certain way right
yeah well it's more it's more
treacherous right yeah it's more
dangerous there could be things like
that right and one of the things that i
am very i want to mention is that all of
our packaging is recyclable
we actually have a f fsc
rating on our box which we have a little
stamp on the on the bottom
and the only thing that is not
recyclable is the cheese paper because
it's touched the cheese
and it gets the oils in it and you can't
recycle that
so anyway it's an exciting time i am
in the sort of mindset of creating my
own reality
uh and i think this is an opportunity
for all of us right now and it ties
back into the beginning of our
conversation and that is that we have
the power to create our own reality
during this time
and remembering that thoughts are things
and what you put your attention on
is what you put energy to and so i
believe in all of us
i believe in humanity humans are
innovative we are
empathic we are devoted we are capable
we are genius everybody has a genius
within themselves
and so um you know we have to work
the work is in creating a different
mindset when we have so many factors
that are pressing on us
we have to do whatever we can to change
that lens
so that we can be amplifying love and
creativity and hope and the new systems
and so i want to encourage everybody to
rise
up and go within and understand that
you're needed and you have something of
value to share
and we need you so um i am
embarking right now i'm going out for my
first raise
my first proper raise um and so we're
going to be raising 3.3 million
um for a four-year strategy um that's
going to take us
to do about 24 million and um
so i am aligning with my
beautiful angel i actually want to give
him a shout out steve
steve barr what's up steve i have the
most
beautiful human being who is my angel
um he is just an extraordinary
light on this planet and i feel so
blessed
to have him close i also want to give a
shout out to
chris murphy and save earth and chris
blair
who also supported me in the early days
so now here we go we're going to be
really looking for that
person or group of people that are
really aligned and hopefully
strategically aligned
because i have the capacity to go wider
with this
i mean i'm this what we see on this
board is just the very beginnings
and i'm the artist i'm the founder i'm
the creator i will hold the spiritual
frequency
and i am dedicated with every aspect of
my being to making this a global brand
and i am you know open for that other
team of individuals who have the
resources
skill set genius um that can collaborate
with me
to really bring shrimu to the planet
spoken like a true startup founder
who believes in her mission and her
product
i love it i'm so proud of you it's super
exciting
um i know it's gonna be wildly
successful
and it is great and you have made really
wise choices about the people to
associate with and you know the two
chris's
and steve barr i mean they're just
they're all like amazing wonderful
people
so you are guided by
uh deft hands thank you so much so if
anybody out there
if you think you're that person uh is
that a hiring call i have a new email
address actually just for just for
hiring prospects yeah juliepyat
shrimu.com send me an email you're gonna
get
quite a few emails i think i always like
it when i give out my email on your show
it always turns into something amazing
um
well that's very cool i'm excited for
you and like i said i
you know it couldn't be a better time
people are pivoting in this direction
um and even i i did also want to mention
that miyoko
you know miyoko's creamery you know goes
a friend and she's built this amazing
you know uh company in this space and
she just
fought this battle because she was told
by the state of california that she
couldn't use the word butter
lactose free or cruelty free on any of
her product labels
uh and there was this whole lawsuit um
the state was demanding that she cease
using those terms and she
was also like a picture of her hugging a
cow remember when you had
that picture too yeah um and she
prevailed
so this is i i think it's just
indicative
you know it's a symbol it's
representative of changing times and
changing consumer trends as people look
to live more cruelty free more
sustainably and and obviously healthier
definitely and also just you know great
respect for her
because she is really the pioneer the
first person that
was creating plant-based cheese and it's
because of her that i was able to
sell my book and um anyway she's uh
she did amazing work for us in this
space and
we're here to stay um this is only going
to get bigger
and uh and and the taste is here so
yeah so closing
words of wisdom for the young
aspiring startup founder
well it's always a spiritual adventure
for me
um i don't think there's a separation
and i think
um understanding that each one of us was
created
in this complete unique blueprint
there's none of us
are the same and so if you can really
identify what it is that you love
what it is that is unique to you
that is so unusual or so
authentic i would feed that
and i would really stay true and
understand that
cultivating that connection will
will prove out will benefit you it might
not go exactly the way you think it's
going to go
but understand that you know a lot and
if you
cultivate the practices to go within and
really find out what you want to
dedicate your life to
and and why you've taken a body what it
is you want to express and share
then that will be supported and you will
be
further along than if you um compromise
or go outside of yourself and try to do
it
like another person does it i think
again it comes down to those moments in
the middle of the night
by the fire in the alchemical right
ceremony what time did you wake up this
morning
three
[Laughter]
when i came in this morning i could
smell the fire so i knew
something some kind of witchcraft had
gone down
it's safe by the way it's right by a
huge body of water and there's nothing
around it so it's well
well kept well thank you for sharing
thank you for having me on your show
love it i love you i love you i'm
excited for
what is to come um for everybody out
there who
is digging on julie and wants to learn
more about her
universe there's plenty of outlets to do
just that
to learn about the cheese shreemu.com
srimu.com that's where you can
uh uh see all the stuff and become a
subscriber
julie also has a podcast you want to
talk about
for the life of me yeah yeah and so
check in
with me there for upcoming podcasts on
spiritual perspectives of current events
it's usually just me
rarely i have a guest on but it's
usually just me reflecting on
current events or spiritual perspectives
of how we can truly live a life divine
and if you want to really dive deep into
the spiritual universe with her
uh check out her community
water tiger you do these monthly calls
uh and really you really spend a lot of
time cultivating that community
yeah you can learn about that on your
website at juliepiet.com
yeah it's very deep and it's uh it's for
everyone by the way so don't feel
intimidated there is no
hierarchy in spiritual spirituality we
are all spiritual beings having a human
experience
um but water tiger i have to say i'm
quite proud with my
design of that um because it's
um it's designed and crafted to give
individuals techniques to lead them
deeper into the sense of who they are
so um it's not about building a tie to
me
or any any ideology that i have
it's about empowering you to be a free
being
and so those techniques and meditations
are ones that i
develop um to support you in that
connection
all right how do you feel i feel pretty
good thank you so much
you're welcome thank you for sharing uh
to be continued
at some point in the not too distant
future awesome
love you babe love you thank you peace
plants
[Music]
namaste
so
[Music]
you